hey what's up guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at
instrumentation and in fact we've kind
of had this profiling series that we've
been taking a look at check it out if
you haven't already it's really
interesting stuff even if you think that
it's not necessary to take a look at
that now you're not interested in it at
all
believe me you will be at some point
because there's gonna come a point if
your application if anything a building
gets large enough where you're actually
gonna want to take a look at it and see
what it is is slowing it down and have
more of like a holistic view of your
applications even doing I want to take a
break from that kind of stuff right now
because again as I mentioned it's not
something that we necessarily need to
actually be looking at right now it's
it's very important to have that system
set up because it'll be really vital in
the future but when are at the stage
where we have to actually diagnose
issues with performance in our engine
whatsoever
what I do want to do instead is take a
look at a few little clean up things
that we can do in preparation for taking
kind of the next step with this engine
but also just because the last video
that I made I actually made a game in
one hour using hazel definitely check
out that video if you guys happen
because it's really super interesting to
take a look at what Hazel's kind of
capable of and also this is the first
time I have sat down and decided okay
I'm gonna sit down I'm gonna make an
entire game start to finish as quickly
as possible using this engine and other
people from the community have actually
made little games like I know someone
made like the game of life or some kind
of little test like that it's a long it
kind of the discord if you're guys not
part of the discord I'll leave a link in
the description below that is called
it's just like a community where people
talk about all sorts of things including
hazel and you know share things that
they've made and suggestions and all of
that stuff it's a really cool community
definitely check it out but um I sat
down I made a game and I realized that
well it's not like I didn't see this
coming but I realized that okay there's
a lot of things and hazel needs and
there's a lot of current things in hazel
that can be improved I'm gonna make a
video pretty soon about actually taking
a look at like that game that I made and
dissecting it and in that video also
probably make like some kind of list
that just shows what I think we need to
do with
all major features as well as kind of
little adjustments that I think will
kind of go a long way as well as like
you know adding cross-platform support
and all these other kind of fixes are
exhilarating things I like to call them
because they're not central to core
functionality it's more like just across
the board making the end product the
game a little bit more shippable and a
little bit more polished as well as the
experience with hazel a little bit
better basically but anyway check out
that video I'll have it linked over
there it's really cool fun video to
check out and today we're just gonna
take a look at some of the minor things
that I want to make but these are
directly things that I've said in that
video or I'm like hey you know what I
have to change this or I have to
actually go into Hazel's code and modify
Hazel's code to make it work that's not
good because in that video I did have to
actually go into the hazel project and
modify specifically that render a 2d
file and the actual default shader as
well because it just wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't doing what I needed it to do
so we definitely need to fix that stuff
the first one I give a huge thank you to
all the patrons that made this series
possible patreon home force - the
churner is the best place to help
support this series and everything that
I do here on YouTube there's actually a
behind-the-scenes video that I've just
released this week on that other video
that I made so that stuff's it is
available to patrons as well as access
to the developing branch of hazel and
other kind of source projects that I
work on definitely check that out and
huge thank you of course to everyone who
supported this to make this possible sir
let's dive in take a look at a few
different things and a few little issues
and we'll kind of just fix them up okay
so the first issue comes from us
actually launching this this is great
everything's fine here but obviously
this texture the texture that we're
looking at that checkerboard texture is
not actually the texture that we're
trying to render if we look at the
checkerboard texture you can see that
it's this big right it's as clearly does
not have like a billion like cells it's
got 8x8 cells and that's what the
texture looks like whereas if we open
hazel its tiling it a lot which is fine
that was to demonstrate I guess tiling
but unfortunately that car literally
lives inside the shader here it is it's
this ten is this it's us multiplying our
texture coordinates by ten meaning that
now our quad is between zero and ten in
the X&Y texture coordinate' instead of
zero and one and that's why we get that
effect because we have repeat we're
repeating our texture past it's balanced
now this also has to do with the texture
filtering setting well no specifically
the filtering settings but the actually
turn to remember what the coals we'll
just take a look the the wrapping
settings right so I'll wrap at the
moment is hot carded to be GL repeat
that's not the only rapid we have
there's also you know GL clamshell clamp
to edge I think clam and clamped ever
the same does clamp to border and clamp
to edge but I think clamp is just climb
to edge anyway
um in fact maybe we can take a look here
in our clamp has its own ID anyway
clamp a clamp to edge with only resource
we can use clamp here but basically if
we were to change this to clamp to edge
for example we'd get a very different
effect from our shader because now if
the text recording is opposed to an
amount actually I'm just speaking
rubbish on this is if we're creating the
texture using not a file so let's just
put that clamp to edge into the function
that loads the - profile you can see we
got something very different because it
takes that last pixel and just repeats
it instead of actually repeating the
ties texture like we saw before
basically just like using a modulus
operator and looping through those
pixels so this is something that needs
to be taken in as parameters as some
kind of texture properties and we are
gonna do that eventually but will still
leave this as a repeat for now because I
think repeats slightly more useful them
clamp is just a default kind of mode and
then what we're actually gonna do is go
back into this shader and we're gonna
modify it to actually still have this
property because we don't want to change
the functionality I don't want to get
rid of it and then suddenly be faced
with something like this where it's just
like this is not the result I want and I
also don't want to make a huge texture
with really kind of you know I mean
that's gonna be a quite a high
resolution texture and it's completely
unnecessary because here all I want to
do is actually tile everything so what
I'm gonna do is add a new uniform called
it's going to be like tiling faster
anything like that and then what this is
gonna be I don't even know like tile
multiply or tile tiling fax I don't know
what it would name that this is I
actually think that I will bullet while
in fact sir I kind of liked that and
then this what this is gonna be it's
just a uniform that we multiply without
extra coordinates like that I don't know
why I did em underscore and then this is
something that will enable us to it'll
just be set to one by default by our end
Ridge PD and it's super easy to add
these uniforms by the way you can see
that what I'm doing here is basically
you know inside a drill quad for example
when I'm drawing anything like that if I
just want to set that I can easily just
say you know and start at extra shader
set floor and then you know you tiling
factor and then we know we'll just set
that to 1 by default and then that's
kind of it
right really easier to have this done
this way which is cool set flow doesn't
exist okay ignore me saying this was
easy because this is hazel nothing
apparently seems to be easy but we'll
just quickly add that in we are going to
eventually transition to uniform buffers
and have more of an API agnostic way of
doing things that's definitely coming
but while that doesn't exist I don't
want to make the engine completely
unusable so I'm gonna add all of these
kind of functions here even though it
kind of pains me to do so so we'll add
in the cette Fleur yeah said as pure
virtual here in the base class and then
we will just implement it and we'll
basically copy everything from here and
this will be upload uniform Floyd okay
that's done right so now going back to
renderer 2d which is over here we can
just have that flow in that tiling
factor has been set now we need to
remember to set that everywhere we
actually want the time factor obviously
instead of setting it to one for example
if we're doing a crab rendering a color
you we like we could not care less what
it is because it's not gonna be a it's
not gonna be a factor at all because
obviously what we do if we render a
color is we bind the white texture and
that's just a that's a one-by-one
texture so tiling is not gonna have any
effect on that whatsoever but for the
other ones that does matter so you could
argue that like there's no reason to set
tiling factor and I guess like if you
really want it to be optimal here then
wouldn't set this uniform at all it's a
waste of time however in reality when we
do the full uniform buffer upload which
is what we'll have to do for this stuff
in the future it's not gonna matter if
one float is one value or another so
I'll leave this in here is almost like a
little guide to us telling us what
uniforms were using and then you know I
mean I promise you we won't see a
performance difference if we remove this
anyway okay so we have these two paths
that's great
let's test this out the other problem
though is that like I want a tiling
factor right we don't need to add this
to this API there's clearly not gonna be
Italian factor for remembering colors
but if I do add something like a you
know floor tiling factor equals to one
point zero if like that so it's a
default parabola everything's nice um
it's still kind of making this a little
bit like congested right so we want to
draw a record but suddenly we have a
billion parameters like that's not
something that I really want we could
have a lot of overloads what we just
have like you know kind of like what we
have here with this vector two with
respect to in vector E right so we're
kind of splitting it up making it
support bars and that's really nice but
you know on the other hand I want to
have a billion draw port function so
what I sometimes like to do and what I
actually did in that video where I did
make that game in an hour with the
particle system specifically is I made a
function called like particle properties
or something like that so like a struct
called particle properties and then that
had like what like 20 parameters ten
parameters in it that you could control
and then what I did was I just passed
that struct in and that structure just
have default values and everything like
that it's got a runtime cost to have a
struct instead of like a bunch of you
know just parameters I guess for a
function and in that way it's just one
parameter you pass me one parameter and
that's it not only that but that stroggs
can be created by a class as like a
member variables set up once and then
you can only change parts of it that you
care about changing so it's almost like
a template right now like I say bossboss
template but like an actual template and
you just kind of pass in that template
we're just modifying the areas that you
want to make you need to that specific
particle such as its starting position
its emission position and then you just
you provide that struct to the to the
actual like mmm in that case particle
system in this case trial court function
and it has all the data it needs anyway
so that's something that I will consider
for the future
probably not instead of this stuff but
just in addition to this stuff because
sometimes you know like for example I
you know I have this letter say how I
play a character I want to render it
right it's always gonna have a constant
color or a constant texture it's gonna
always have a constant I'll in fact a
constant size
the thing that is variable is position
so why do I have to set all those
properties every single time that I want
to you know call this draw quad function
it'll be easier in that case to have
like a quote properties or quad whatever
what variables board settings not
settings I had a different word but
anyway quad properties right to have
that kind of structure that has
everything filled out and then we just
changed the part that we care about
changing again definitely a viable thing
to do I do that often but I didn't do
this yeah yet in this case so now that
we have the tiling factor we can pass
that in here instead now if we launch
this we should see absolutely no
difference it would expect to see a
difference at all because you know we've
added a default parameter and we've also
set it to one in most cases yeah we
don't have anything here at all but if I
do go into sandbox 2d and what we
actually draw our checkerboard texture
which we draw last here what I can do is
at a time factor of ten as we had before
and that's basically saying tile that
checkerboard texture ten times over
right in both horizontally and
vertically and then we kind of have our
familiar result yes that's the first
step that I want to make that's one of
the first things in that video where I
didn't make the game now I keep saying
what that be if I say that video you
guys know what I'm talking about anyway
in that video that was one of the first
things that I did I had to actually go
into the texture shader and be like why
is my player 2 extra being tiled ten
times over
right not something you want to do when
you have an out of menu game engine
should just have that immediately it's
like taken care of so but by adding this
parameter by adding this actual like my
guest parameter that we can modify when
we actually draw a textured quad we
still have that ability to actually tile
that texture without you know completely
changing our shader or having to do
something custom in the client-side
rendering code okay onwards so the other
thing that was really important in a
kind of a big deal was the fact that I
could not rotate my ship at all my
player ship I had to do also going to
the renderer to D it actually add a
rotation so we don't have that so we
have it seems a good place to add up
between position size and then rotation
right so flow of rotation and then we
should support attention for everything
I can't make it a default parameter
because it's before like this stuff
which makes me question again you know
whether or not we want to actually have
this anywhere whatsoever
this is totally something that you can
do but you should also probably you
could also take into consideration the
fact that a rotated quad might be
something completely different for you
and your renderer then something that is
like access aligned right and because of
that instead of adding a flow rotation
here another viable thing to do is that
a completely different function that's
called something like draw rotated quad
right instead of just again adding and
adding an overload so draw rotated quad
for example is specifically saying that
I want this quad to be rotated that
means I'm ready to accept an additional
matrix matrix multiplication I guess and
add construction all right
that's like a mixture because because it
is an extra cost to say that I can
rotating this right like we have our
transform here and you can see the
transform which I definitely will
represent like this from now on so you
can see everything the transform at the
moment is just simply a translation and
scale but what we're saying if we want a
rotation it was always saying we're
going to add in a GLM rotate you know
we're constructing this matrix here
there's the rotation matrix and then
we're having to multiply that with like
the translation and the scale which is
an extra it's an extra matrix multiplied
it's an extra mint it's an extra matrix
generation and a rotation matrix is not
easy to generate I mean look at this
right we have quite a lot of maths going
on here including cosine and sine so got
trigonometry we've got bunch of
multiplications and you know additions
subtractions there's quite a lot of
stuff to construct here it's not as
simple as say a projection matrix or a
you know a translation matrix which is
you know dead simple I mean or a scale
matrix let's take a look at this so
translate that's the whole translation
matrix and scale you know that's this is
the whole scale matrix nothing basically
to do what so
but a rotation is like a big deal as you
can see might not be something you want
to incur every time you render and
access the land quad so because of that
what we're actually gonna do is separate
it out that way and make this like
specifically that's that draw rotated
quad which will have like a rotation
because I don't think it's that often
that we necessarily want rotated quads
you know like in a lot of scenarios you
would never really rotate something like
your animation within that chord might
have certain rotations associated with
it but usually like usually I don't want
to say usually just because you could I
can't think of everything you could
possibly make with hazel right now while
I'm sitting here making this video but
as far as I can tell this there's
usually quite that there's a lot of
scenarios in which you don't care about
rotation whatsoever but just not
something you want ever and for that I
also want to provide like a fast card
pause for that specific scenario since
Edie is quite and a frequent thing to
want okay so this is going to be the
color version of that and then I also
want to have a non colors of a texture
version of that which we will also have
a tiling factor for that because we
might as well okay so now we have this
specifically here again this is like a
back to version whether or not we want
to effect three version is again no kind
of up to you I guess I guess I will do
that just for completion you can see
that we you know designing like an API
and this by the way she got a copy of
this designing an API that can handle
anything is quite a lot of work
specifically with just you know minor
changes I guess here and there let's go
ahead and try and implement all of these
methods at once but you know the the
payoff obviously is the fact that you
know you can kind of basically give it
any kind of data you want the other
thing that is difficult or with this is
to make sure that you're not actually
accidentally introducing errors because
it's very easy to make this API is so
extensive that people aren't gonna know
what to do
and sometimes they might actually use
the wrong thing and that can be
obviously quite dangerous so that's just
something to consider okay so I'm
filling these things in this is the
texture and tiling factor version
especially if you don't have like a
testing like that sandbox or some kind
of unit test that actually tests all
these functions make sure you haven't
accidentally forgotten something when
you've done it like incorrectly so yeah
it can definitely kind of end up being
rather hard to do
okay so draw quad again I'll copy this
and so what this is gonna have is this
isn't the time this is the point where
we don't care about time factor so I
probably should have copied the other
one let's put this into the texture
version this is the untextured version
just the color version so we'll grab
that and paste that into here so tiling
factor we'll leave it one here we're
binding our white texture and I am going
to just pop you this and paste it and
this is going to become our GLM rotate
and then we will rotate this is a 2d
renderer so we can just rotate in the
z-axis and then so German I think it's
fair to say that it should already be in
radians at this point we don't want to
incur that cost always in the city
renderer of having to convert between
radians and not especially if someone's
willing someone so if someone wants to
to do their rotation in radians for
whatever reason maybe it's coming from a
camera or it's already in radians
obviously you have to give back to
degrees and to pass it into this
function which will then convert into
radians it's just a waste of waste of
everyone's time so we'll just we'll have
it and assuming the rotation is already
in radians basically which you could
annotate as part of the comment or as
part of the actual variable name but I'm
not gonna bother doing that because I
think that should be obvious okay so
there we go I think that's it really all
we've done is we've got a rotation I
think that should be okay let's test
this out obviously what I'll do is I
will well let's just try and rotate this
checkerboard
textures a little drawer a rotated quad
and then after the sighs I'll just say
GLM radians and we'll just rotate at 45
degrees that should be pretty easy to
actually see so let's take a look at
that
okay cool clearly at a 45 degree angle
here looking pretty good and then I
guess we'll try a colored quad as well
that will rotate so maybe let's take the
red one which is this one and let's just
try and rotate that negative 45 degrees
there we go so that should be now Rose
headed the other way and I mean I mean
I'm saying the other way but since
there's no texture on it and doesn't
matter if we rotate it negative 45
degrees or positive positive 40 or 45
degrees okay so we're pretty much in
line here cool looking good sir we can
now drew rotation and rotated quads
which is nice I might leave this red
quad rotated but I will maybe a reset
this to just be dropped like so I mean I
quite like this API of like specifically
explicitly having to write whether or
not something is rotated I think that's
pretty good because it just you know it
forces you to use the right function if
you don't want rotation and all that
stuff just because it is like we know
it's more expensive to do a rotated
quite even though it's not that much
more expensive so yeah it just really
makes you think
and finally the last thing that I want
to address is this kind of hue shift
effect that I had to do for that game in
that video and that was to do with us
being able to actually multiply a color
to tint our texture now to do that we
need to actually we've already got that
set up in the shader we just have no API
exposing it so we really need to add
something called a tint color that will
actually be able to ten everything is
again if you're just drawing like a
simple like non textured quad or
anything it's that is just the color of
the quad it's easy to do it but if it's
specifically something that is 10 that
is textured like our checkerboard
background that needs to actually have
an API exposed to tint it with a certain
color so let's go ahead and do that
again we come to the the kind of
the problem here of we have so much of
these functions and we've already got
four parameters do we just add another
default parameter we make like draw
tinted quad what are we going to
actually do so I don't think there's a
correct solution for this I mean we've
got Italian factor for a texture which
you could also argue should be maybe
texture properties which you can also
pass in here and then maybe tint should
also be a texture property what I'm
gonna do for now though is literally
just add it as a kind of parameter maybe
that we have at the end we've decided to
add tiling factor as you know a quad
that's not tiled maybe this was
something that we should have added as
like a draw tiled quad and then a draw
tinted chord instead of doing that we
just had draw cord with texture and a
tint color again whether or not we want
to kind of do anything like that it's
it's hard to decide and so right now
I'll probably choose just one of these
possibilities and then as someone makes
a game or as I make a game or as I just
you know time passes and I realized that
actually probably would have been better
to do it this way I'll probably change
it so just being honest with you guys
I'm not gonna sit here and say okay this
is the final hazel API this is clearly
in development will probably change a
lot of these things for now I'm just
gonna just chuck it in the ended drawer
Quadra so that we at least support that
specific code pod so at the end of draw
pod
I'll just add EMEA Const ll be back for
tint color and then we'll set it equal
to GL m at 41.0 F okay so we have it
default being one here and then I'll
grab this and I'll chuck it into the and
we have to add this for right for rotate
quads as well by the way so maybe I'll
do that now I'll just grab this and add
that here because this has to this has
to be available for all textured quads
so drawer ahead quad that's the non-test
that here is the texture version so
we'll just carry that comment and put it
in here as a tint color which which is
what you color will be so 10 color is
becoming that and then over here as well
we'll add this in
so tiling factor at the end of that
we're just adding the tint color we have
to remember to add it into the other
spot here by the way you can enter color
although I didn't forget okay and then
over here instead of 1.0 we add in our
tint color okay cool so to test that out
back in sandbox 2d or we need to do is
for our our draw quad here we'll just
try and tip that a certain color maybe
like a kind of and remember anything
closer to one is gonna will tend to kind
of read and it because the 1 means no
change right so this isn't like it's
being added in as a 10 it's it's really
just being subtracted here in a way so
like if we leave the red Channel at 1
but then we set the green and blue
channels to 0.9 then we're actually
subtracting green and blue and then wet
we're kind of keeping read at the same
mouth it's almost like we're adding red
but really we're subtracting the other
channel so let's take a look at that and
then we'll try the road headed version I
guess as well just to make sure yeah
okay so we can see we have an ever so
slight red tint here and then again I'll
just change this control rotated quad
all out in some kind of rotation just to
make it super obvious
we'll try maybe 90 degrees which should
be no rotation maybe it will do
something like 80 degrees so it's quite
slide and then that should also be
tinted red as you would expect and it is
okay cool
so there we go that's kind of the
tinting in effect which was important
for the game because I needed to have
kind of a huge shift affect my kasha to
draw a triangle that was like a texture
instead of an actual triangle because
hazel control triangles but also because
I needed to have like a glow effect
which we can't do without
processing anyway alright I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please hit that like button don't forget
to help support the series on this
channel on patreon because your support
is what makes stuff possible and I'm
really happy to say that I'm able to do
this because of the lovely people who do
help support this so thank you so much
for that next time I think what we'll do
before next time probably is I will make
that kind of looking back video a
retrospective kind of debrief video of
taking a look at that game that I did
make in an hour and then we'll kind of
make a list of what we need to do and I
think the first kind of step to do
specifically in hazel is gonna be to try
and add in all those engine features
perhaps to make that game a lot easier
to make it's really good to kind of set
a goal and then work towards it which is
kind of how I like to work and how I
think we should progress here obviously
I want to you know continue on with you
rendering and adding stuff like batch
rendering font rendering post-processing
even all that stuff but again with
having that kind of game that I did make
which is like a popular clone you know
with having data is like our end goal
almost four to eight game I know it's a
very simple 2-d game it's just made like
in and out or so obviously it's simple
but having that is kind of like an end
goal and then being able to add all the
energy features to support more unity
like approach I guess to making that
game is kind of what we're aiming for
right now and then I'll probably
eventually have like a planning triage
and kind of goal-setting episodes loss
but we can clearly define what we're
gonna do next year anyway hope you guys
enjoy this video and I will see you next
time goodbye
[Music]